You can look at these ancient hills and see nothing,...
...or you can see nothing to hold you back.
No set ways of thinking, no restrictions, no divisions, no excuses,...
...just endless potential.
This is the blank page you need to write humanity's next chapter:...
...Neom.
Over 25,000 square kilometers of inspiration...
...with room for your biggest ideas,...
...a part of the world set aside for those who want to change the world,...
...a land created to free people from stress,...
...a place where pioneers and thinkers and doers...
...can exchange ideas and get things done.
A startup the size of a country...
...that will change the way we live and work forever,...
Healthier, happier with more time for the things that really matter.
A truly global culture from every place and background you can imagine...
...that can show the rest of the planet how it's done...
...with energy that flows from the sun and wind,...
...neighborhoods that can feed and clean themselves,...
...technologies that make life everything it can be.
This is where we can prepare together for the next era of human progress.
Some will look at these ancient hills and see nothing,...
...but the rest of the world will know that this is where a new way of living began.
Discover Neom.